l'allée des tilleuls des mesnuls connaît
une seconde vie le département des mines
vient de replanter en cette fin d'année
de jeunes arbres le long de la rd 191
ils remplaceront les 75 tilleuls
bicentenaire a battu en urgence de 2018
à 2020 suite à l'apparition de
champignons parasites
nous avons procédé à la plantation 246
sujet du jeune tout beau plein de
vigueur et qui vont pour les années à
venir les décennies à venir pouvoir
permettre d'avoir une allée des tilleuls
comme au temps jadis pour replanter
c'est à bhl département gestionnaire de
cette route a choisi de regarder les
plans historique de 1836 les documents
prévoyait notamment d'implanter les
tilleuls selon les alignements double
aux abords du château
nous sommes dans un patrimoine
historique et il nous a été recommandé
fortement recommandé de pouvoir procéder
puisqu'il y avait replantation au plan
2836 et à partir de là on a gardé le
même alignement et le même espacement
entre chacun des sujets coût total de
l'opération 300000 euros chaque jour
près de 5000 véhicules circulent sur cet
axe